what's going on everyone i want to show
you in this video one of the fastest
ways to make a tremendous amount of
money in a service business all right so
right now if you want a service business
or any kind of business where you
provide stuff uh to customers if you
sell stuff then this video is for you um
just so you if you don't know me my
name's alex romozy i own acquisition.com
we do about 85 million a year in revenue
i have nothing to sell you um and this
channel is just because a lot of people
are broke and i don't want you to be one
of them all right so uh i was thinking
about the different businesses that we
have um we have a publishing business we
have a photography business which is a
chain of brick and mortar um somebody
asked me in one of the comments to name
them out i don't tell you the actual
names of these because part of the deal
structure that we have with a lot of
these are our influencer based or
personality driven brands and so i don't
want it to be like oh you're just one of
alex's businesses all right so just to
be clear for everybody the reason i
don't do that i'll tell you the ones
that i own 100 of but the ones where i'm
a minority partner in
i don't um i don't tell you what they
i'll tell you what categories they're in
um so like i said we've got a publishing
business uh which is a digital uh
digital business we have a brick and
mortar chain photography studios we have
we have a certification
business
we also have a an online it's a similar
business but online for trainers
we have our gym
licensing business uh which is gym
launch we have our supplement business
which is prestige labs um and then uh we
have allen which is our software uh
company for for agency owners that helps
brick and mortar agencies uh work leads
all right so just so you're curious
that's what we do and we're looking
getting some others anyways one of the
things i was thinking about within our
businesses is like what are the
different categories and this was kind
of a spin-off of the recurring video
that i made about cracking netflix's
code right is what are the different
types of products that we can sell and
i'll show you one of these that's
incredibly valuable that if you're ever
pressed for cash it's the easiest thing
that you can sell for a ton of money
first there i was like you've got
products right you've got widgets you've
got stuff all right that's the first
category the second category let me see
if i can draw some nice lines here the
second category is you've got services
right where people do stuff right for
other people and the third and this is
the one that a lot of people miss out on
is access all right so i'm gonna go
through all three of these in a second
all right so products everyone should
kind of understand what these are right
you get these in the mail and they can
also be digital goods so here's a here's
an aab version of each of these right so
you've got physical
and then you've got digital so you've
got physical product would be getting
you know supplements in the mail a
digital product would be uh uh buying
buying the buying netflix uh like you
know buying a netflix subscription right
that's where you're you're consuming a
digital good when you buy media that is
a digital good right you're buying
eyeballs right if you're buying physical
services that would be like buying a
massage you've got digital services
which would be like um like a marketing
agency it would be a digital service
right they're not actually buying
you're not buying something that's going
to happen in the real world you're happy
you're buying something that's happening
in the digital in the digital sphere
right third is access where you've got
physical access which would be like uh
concert tickets right you have access
like to someone or to an experience of
some sort and then you've got digital
access right which would be uh you you
buy access either to um
like a virtual a virtual event or or you
have access to me via slack or something
like that right that would be digital
access all right and so when you're
thinking about your products and
services right one of the easiest things
to do to make it more valuable is think
how can i add if you have let's say
products how can i add some sort of
service component to it to make this
more valuable and we do this so that we
cannot be a commodity right the goal is
to be so different from everyone else in
the marketplace that people have to
consider you on their own as your own
standalone business so that you can have
monopoly prices all right despite what
the government will tell you in
antitrust laws the goal is to become a
monopoly like you win the game by being
monopoly by being so good that no one
else can compete with you right and now
because those companies have so much
power they own the government now
anyways not getting into that that's not
the point but the point is
is that uh you can pair these concepts
so most people just consider themselves
i am just a physical products business
it's like okay well can we add some sort
of digital products right to our
physical products to enhance the value
and differentiate ourselves if i have a
service i have a physical service maybe
i can add some sort of digital component
to it or maybe i can add some physical
products that go with it or digital
products right they go with it or
thirdly is there a way that i can add
access which is probably one of my
favorite
of the types of of of businesses and
here's why this one
has almost
100 margins right digital access is
almost 100 margins same thing with
digital products almost 100 margins
right um digital services less so so
services just so you're you're wondering
why so many service businesses have a
hard time scaling this is very hard to
scale people it's also hard to scale
things that have hard costs right um and
scaling people you have to scale culture
you have to scale training you have to
scale onboarding there's a lot of things
you have to scale for scaling services
which is why most people don't like
buying those types of businesses which
is why and i'm making this video right
now if you want to increase your
enterprise value it's trying to figure
out how you can add multiple of these
things so i just gave you six different
categories here right of things of
different types of things that you can
have in your business i know that the
sun is making me
you know
i'm dodging the sun here right i'm a sun
chaser right now when you're thinking
about how you can add more value right
and i'll tell you the hack right now all
right so you guys ready for this in
terms of if you needed to make money the
way that you do this all right this is
my favorite one that you can use which
is access all right i'm gonna put this
in big
is that you sell
a more individualized higher touch
version of your own solution all right
and so what that means is you can say
hey i can only take five people for a
one on one
right or a small group right experience
for one year
for this big outcome
that they're all gonna want
and i'll guarantee
that you'll get it
or i'll keep working with you for free
until you do which means
when you buy this thing and when you
give me this money right now it means
that you've solved this problem you can
put this money down it means that that
outcome is going to happen i'm going to
try and get it to happen 12 months
because i don't want to keep working for
free but you know that i will continue
to work with you until you achieve it
all right so right now if you have a
client base and you're like man i'm
strapped for cash and the only way that
they can do this is if they prepay the
entire period of time all right and so
the thing is you don't need to have any
kind of discount for an offer that's
structured like this the reason that
they're getting a lot of value is
because they're getting access right
they're getting access in addition to a
service all right and they're getting
some level of expertise on top of it
all right and so right now if you need
to make an extra five grand 10 grand 20
grand 50 grand whatever it is that you
have depending on the size of your
business that is one of the easiest
fastest ways to generate cash flow for
your business and use up some of the uh
audience while still maintaining good
pent-up demand all right what i mean by
that is that if you sell
a hundred of these or you sell out in
terms of like you sell out all the
demand that's there you running
something else in the future will bomb
right and so the idea is if you know
that you could sell 20 people sell five
if you know you could sell 100 people
sell 20 right try and maintain the vast
majority 80 of the demand still there
and have it pent up so that when you do
another offer like this in the future
you'll sell out again and the idea is
that as you grow the number of people
that you will have in that demand pool
continue to increase
and so you will always be able to sell
out but the number of total slots will
continue to increase whereas most people
always go for the biggest ass they
possibly can try and sell out and
liquidate all the goodwill they have in
their audience all the time which means
they're always searching for building up
the next demand which is why they're
always poor because it's very hard to do
that all right it's much easier to
maintain goodwill and multiply it and
then feed and then just skim a tiny
amount off the top and then grow the
goodwill of the base to go from you know
100 people in your base who want to buy
the thing to 200 people in the base and
the next time you go from 20 to 40
rather than going from 20 to 200 right
because you could do it but then after
that you're done
nothing you got to start from scratching
it and so it's much better
to always keep some goodwill uh kept up
one of my favorite ways to liquidate
that uh in a very controlled burn manner
is to have access so you can have
implied urgency and applied scarcity uh
with a very very high ticket premium and
you'll probably get some of the best
customers to do this with you they'll be
the least needy believe it or not um and
get some great great testimonials and
great outcomes as a result of it so um
anyways moseynation like i said my name
is dr wozzie on acquisition.com uh with
85 million dollars here and i have
nothing to sell you if you enjoyed this
video uh hit subscribe i share other
stuff like this that's helped us scale
our businesses um and i have absolutely
nothing to sell you all right so keep
being awesome and if you didn't enjoy
this video i still love you anyways and
i'll see you guys the next bit bye